Media reaction to president Trump's
canceling the North Korean summit
mirrored the reaction to the
announcement of the summit
it was scorn and derision well to them a
loss for the president is more important
than a success for America or even for
world peace back on March 8 when
President Trump first delivered news of
the summit with Kim jong-un the left and
the media were in shock how could Trump
of all people suddenly have a shot at
forging peace with this communist
dictatorship maybe even force it to
denuclearize when all of these other
presidents had failed after Trump's war
of words with little rocket Man which
Demme's warned could usher in a nuclear
war the sudden prospect of peace was
frankly just more than they could stand
and somehow they said it was dangerous
State Department our closest allies I'm
sure people on the hill nobody knew
about this Donald Trump just decided but
this is a reality TV show president to
change the headline this is having Trump
and Kim jong-un when both are known to
be volatile you don't know who's going
to try to be the big man in that room it
injects a risk of literally nuclear
proportions it has been the dream of
North Korean leaders for decades now
that they would advance their missile
programs and there were nuclear programs
so much so that the United States would
be forced to acknowledge them as an
equal I don't know whether or not the
administration intended it to be that
kind of a gift Jeffrey Lewis is an
expert in non-proliferation and he wrote
today that Donald Trump agreeing to Kim
jong-un is like quote Richard Nixon
going to China but if Nixon were a [ __ ]
well speaking of morons this crowd and
the prospect of a summit to them was not
only dangerous but the president was a
fool for engaging the North Koreans at
all and now they're shifting narratives
again the same chain of fools is saying
that the cancellation of the summit is
what's really perilous itself and that
trumps impetuous diplomacy and
inexperience of course are at fault the
headline in the Washington Post screamed
Trump impulsively blows up the North
Korea summit the editorial board
blame Trump for what it called a hasty
strategy free improvisation that is
characterized as handling of the
diplomatic opening all along the post
warned never has such chaos attended the
public behavior of a US president on a
matter of such gravity oh and here's how
the Trump hating cable news outlets
reacted for the president to have raised
expectations to the point to say listen
I'm in charge here I got it
we could sit down I'm gonna work this
out was a little unrealistic the art of
diplomacy is a lot harder than the art
of the deal does the administration
actually have a long-term game plan here
I think a lot of people probably are
secretly relieved I don't think it's a
secret I think there's a lot of relief
let's go to Peter Alexander who's live
at the White House Peter this is a huge
Wow for us wait wait did you catch that
oh wow for us bit
well at least Stephanie ruhle is kind of
implicitly admitting that the media do
not exist to report on Trump but to
revel in his perceived missteps that's a
while for us oh my gosh these people
haven't been this happy since I thought
Oprah would run for president thrilled
today well Trump is damned if he does
he's damned if he doesn't we all know
that but might I offer another
possibility here
Trump's retreat from the summit might
have been a grand negotiating tactic not
an admission of failure at all it might
have been a way of testing Kim
seriousness and squeezing maybe a few
more concessions from him the president
has already gotten Little Rock a man to
hand over the American hostages and
they've allegedly detonated that nuclear
testing facility although that might not
be as big a story as we hope that the AP
is reporting that the North violated its
pledge to allow these international
inspectors to monitor the supposed
implosion but this was part of the
reason Trump backed away from the summit
table the North Korean dictator had also
bristled at talk of denuclearizing his
country and that is a non-negotiable for
Trump we also learned that North Korean
officials never showed up for
preliminary talks in Singapore last week
that was a surprise but if you read the
president's letter today
he clearly left the door open to a peace
deal and tells Kim look if you change
your mind having to do with this
important summit please do not hesitate
to call me or write that's like a pen
pal I love that by pulling the plug on
the summit the president may well have
applied the needed pressure and that
tough stance along with continued
economic sanctions and diplomatic
isolation may ultimately convince Kim
jong-un to actually make a serious deal
there are no signs of the Trump strategy
could be working North Korea's Vice
foreign minister and a statement tonight
says our goal and will to do everything
for peace and stability of the Korean
Peninsula and mankind remains unchanged
we're always willing to give time and
opportunity to to us decide with a big
and open mind we express our intent that
there is a willingness to sit at any
time in any way to resolve issues of
course the North Koreans are still
ruling out total denuclearization that's
not really surprising might be a tactic
on their part
my take let the media cheer what they
hope is another Trump setback let them
rally against peace and against American
leadership in the world but behind the
scenes Trump may pull off a peace deal
yet and he might just prove them wrong
once again and that's the angle